hi
i am uh medulla jayaraman
and i go by mj i am a developer and i
work for
thoughtworks who is a software
consulting company i'll tell you a
little more about myself
and my company later on in the
presentation
but i'm here today to talk to you about
a project i got to work on
over the last year and a half and in
this way i learned that developers can
also
help treat ovarian cancer so it was very
exciting and i hope you will be too
so an overview of what my talk's going
to be about is i'll
introduce some of the players involved
to set some context
and in lieu of this i'm also going to
talk a little bit about
some concepts in genomics in cancer
that's relevant
to the domain and then introduce the
problem we were
faced with our solution some key
learnings and then questions
cool so um the key players
let me introduce to you the clarity
foundation they're a not-for-profit
organization started by a woman named
laura
shaver she's an ovarian cancer survivor
and a scientist and having
faced the treatment and all its troubles
and turbulences
she decided to come together she uh
joined along with other women
uh scientists and started clarity so
their goal is to help
relapsed ovarian cancer patients uh find
better alternative
alternate therapies for um for
themselves
so their problem was that they were able
so they came up with a good model
to work with uh the constantly growing
flux of next generation
uh sequencing data and other findings in
the cancer realm
but their trouble was their lack of
technical competence
so they were able to treat about
10 women a month but had the potential
to scale this up and their goal was to
do a thousand women a month
but they didn't have the expertise to
help automate this and take what was in
their brains and actually
put it into a computer algorithm or
sorts
so they met with another company called
an i systems
uh they're a startup um based in the bay
area
and what they really wanted to do is
again to help oncologists and other
researchers who are working in the
cancer realm come up with
ways in which they can commercialize and
actually go help
patients with cancer and help them
again come up with better alternative
alternate
therapies for for these patients
this still doesn't introduce me or
thoughtworks and i'll get to that but
before that we talked about cancer we
talked about
there's a huge word genomic here so i'm
going to jump a little into
the concepts of genomics and cancer
that's relevant
so the first thing is dna um so today
we so in 2003 the first human genome was
sequenced
it was a very expensive process but it
happened and that was
very exciting so what is a genome a
genome is essentially comprised of
dna dna is sort of the building block of
every single human being
and for our purposes let's think about
it as a
continuous stream of characters and
there's four options
a c g or t it's okay if you don't
remember any of this
but just think of it as continuous lines
of ac g or t
going over and over again so we've spent
a lot of time and effort understanding
this
why is this important dna is
what codes for the functional part of
which is a protein
and different proteins come together and
make us who we are and make us function
and define us essentially so um
portions of the dna oftentimes we refer
to them as genes
and this categorization is essentially
we oftentimes when we think gene
it's that part of the dna that ends up
coding for a functional protein
so a functional protein is something
that is then
involved in some other process to help
us function as human beings plants as
plants etc
um so in this process uh the base dna
that today we're getting better and
better at understanding uh goes through
many
processes before it can become a protein
and very quickly i'm going to
introduce this process so a dna
essentially
imagine that it gets cut up and relevant
parts are put together
to first form what is called a pre-mrna
so it's essentially the same strand of
dna becomes mrna
this process is known as transcription
so this then post-processing
where some other irrelevant parts are
taken out and then you put together
just sort of the coding sequence which
eventually can
be translated into the protein again
it's okay if the exact details
is is is not very clear but the
important thing that i want to point out
here
is that we today are understanding this
part really well
but there's still a lot that happens
before we get to a protein
and this is just the happy path um in
in in life um actually what happens is
this process of alternative splicing
so based on which cell it is and what
type of process is involved
your gene or your dna is caught up in
many different combinations
and can result in many different
proteins
so i want to introduce another
terminology here oftentimes
this part up here so whatever is your
particular genetic sequence at a dna
level
is referred to as your genotype
and then what ends up coming out as a
protein is referred to as your phenotype
so for example you have a gene that
codes for eye color
and a lot of us have heard about this
example where
you have a dominant allele and a
recessive allele
again i don't want to get into too many
details but your genotype
uh can have the dominant and the
recessive so two options
and your phenotype is one of the two
options actually showing up and you
having a particular eye color
cool why do we care uh because
again we've gotten better at
understanding dna one thing again i want
to bring up
is that it is a lot of data so dna like
i said was a continuous sequence of acgt
and actually we have 3.2 billion base
pairs
in our 23 chromosomes uh humans actually
have 46 so 23 times two
so we have double this amount of base
pairs all in all but we believe we can
be defined by just one half of it
assuming
they're exactly the same and this is all
for normal ideal happy path scenario
um so out of these 3.2 billion base
pairs
three percent is what actually ends up
as proteins or
functional proteins so in effect today
we're mainly interested in about 25 000
genes
that actually co what that we believe
code for proteins that end up affecting
our bodily functions
um and finally um as i had mentioned
we're getting better at sequencing
but today this data amounts to about
half a terabyte
for one genome so when you sequence you
don't just read things once they read it
over and over and over again
so all together this acg dac gt
you have about half a terabyte of this
data
cool easy huh um so
great again why are we learning about
dna
because of mutations and their effect on
us
so we have these continuous lines of
sequences but each time your cell
divides
or in general based on other
environmental factors
changes happen evolution has caused
changes
in general every single day each of us
are probably
undergoing some form of mutations in our
cellular level
a mutation is simply a change at a base
pair
there's more high level definitions of
this but i'm giving you the simplistic
one
so assume in a particular gene at one
particular position
something changes you can call that a
mutation
um we have normal mutations so like i
said every day our body our cells are
dividing and things are changing
mutations can happen and we have about
um
i would say i think it's 50 000 normal
mutations on average
and that's that's normal so between
myself and someone sitting here
there's a lot of differences and those
are normal differences that we
oftentimes call
germline mutations but the place where
it gets dangerous
is when we get cancer so cancer is a
disease of abnormal gene function
so it is when modifications happen in
your dna
which ends up affecting cell growth or
cell death
we get cancer so our cells start
dividing out of control
and as they divide out of control
they're causing more and more changes
so compared to your normal genome the
cancer genome
is quite different there's lots of
changes happening there and there's also
some important changes there that are
actually causing
a phenotypic implication that is
resulting in this abnormal cell growth
that your normal cells don't have
um so i want to point out that today
we've gotten better at
understanding how to look at the
genotype
and be able to understand more about the
type of cancer
and its prognosis but the place where
there is still a huge huge gap
is in treatment choices so um
before i get more in detail for that i
want to just talk about ovarian cancer
like i said the people i was involved
with was clarity and they were an
ovarian cancer treatment organization
um some facts about ovarian cancer is
that
it is a very lethal type of cancer
it's the fifth it's one of the five most
common cancers affecting women today
in the u.s uh per year there's about 22
000 women who are diagnosed with ovarian
cancer
the thing that's really dangerous about
this is that symptoms are very hard to
detect
when this cancer is in early stages so
people get diagnosed when they get
diagnosed they're already
in advanced stages of this cancer and
out of this
about 14 000 and this number actually
went up a little last year
will die actually almost within six
months of getting diagnosed
so it's terrible the standard of care
today
is organ-based so if they detect you
have ovarian cancer that is your
abnormal cell growth started in the
ovaries
treatment prescribed is targeted at your
ovaries
and less targeted towards the particular
genotypic makeup that is
causing this cancer um this
is the case because again there are a
few options they have worked in the past
research is still growing but this is
sort of what we best know today and
that's why it is
like this it's also incredibly expensive
so for ovarian cancer there's three main
chemotherapy options
especially when you're first diagnosed
each of them costs about a hundred
thousand dollars per round
and they're actually prescribed pretty
much by trial and error so the
oncologist will look at the patient
have some sort of feeling what will work
and then you you
go for the chemotherapy and it it takes
a long time and it's
very painful and there's surgery
involved it's
it's your lifestyle goes way way down
quality of life goes way way down
and it might not work and you'll just
have to do it again
also this type of cancer will recur in
about 80
of the women who get it once so although
your first round of treatment is
successful
the chances of relapsing is pretty high
and the trickiest part is if you do
relapse
the your original options are not valid
anymore because your cells are growing
and as they grow they get resistant to
these drugs you've already been exposed
to
okay so this is a little this is very
depressing but
things are changing so research is
growing where we're getting to
understand
uh details about how the cancer
originated we're also
um essentially growing so much in terms
of how we're able to
start sequencing and getting more
information at a cellular level
available even to oncologists
so i think today in the us you have
about 600
next generation sequencing machinery
available
at the highest quality that we can come
up with right now
the rest of the world combined is 500.
so
there's there's a lot of progress made
in that angle at least to get the data
and this has sort of been in terms of
expense it's following the moore's law
and we hope that within the next year
it's going to cost less than a thousand
dollars
to get any one of us sequenced and get
that data available
so the gap here and the problem that we
were faced with
is yes you have the data what are you
going to do with the data so it needs to
be translated into a viable treatment
option
clarity and an eye then came to
thoughtworks
because both of them had a good idea
about how they can
go from a mutation or a particular
biomarker to a treatment
but they really didn't know how to scale
this and commercialize this at all
and actually have production software if
you will
and this is when they involve
thoughtworks and myself um
to come in and help provide the
technical expertise
to to see this this particular idea
through
so it's very very exciting and we jumped
right in um
superbly excited to tackle this problem
and hopefully
get get things going as quickly as we
could so when we started
i knew this is the information me and my
team had
is that we have a lot of data and at the
at bare minimum we have about half a
terabyte which is the dna sequence data
we do have access to some amount of
cancer as well as normal sequence data
for patients
and we knew from clarity and from an eye
some
way of connecting different sort of
aberrations in a patient's biology
to viable treatment options so we did
have that knowledge
great um so what did we do
we had to start building like we said we
could see
how important it is first the
application itself
as well as this idea and this constantly
changing field
we wanted to get something going as
quickly as possible
given that we had even the slight amount
of knowledge and this idea
so what we did and i'm now going to
actually start showing you
what ended up becoming our our end
architecture
if you will it's not really an
architecture diagram but something of
that sort
and then i'll talk through the
individual steps later so first step was
we wanted to parse um all this immense
amount of data so we knew it wasn't
enough if we just took
what we had which was the sequencing
data you had to contextualize it
in order to be do in order to do
anything with it
so we tapped into many many resources
parsed it
the thing that we i quite enjoyed is we
normalized this data so we didn't choose
one source over another
we grabbed them all and then we try to
unify them and take a union and try to
have as much
uh information as we could get
um we then um again which i quite liked
is made use of internal
dsls or domain specific language i'll
talk more about that later as well
to stuff it into our graph database
so great we built a nice graph of all
this information
and then we went about trying to deduce
useful information
from all this data we have as we went
along
we continuously kept a line of evidence
so
in this world it's not enough if you
just say here's an option
contextualization was key and we needed
to enable
the oncologist or whoever involved to be
able to have a conversation with the
patient
and to also be able to cross-check the
verification of any automated system
or the sorry the output of any automated
system
so all this uh lived here and so finally
when patient x could come along
we could give some treatment options
cool so step one was the data itself
so uh the language we chose to do the
parsing
of all um so this is okay sorry i'm
jumping points but yeah so the language
we chose for parsing
was uh jruby uh the reason we chose this
is because we had aj ruby export on our
team
um and so uh his name is olabini
i think some of you might have heard him
speak in other places but
we could definitely utilize his
expertise to get parsing and
and sort of creation of these dsls done
very efficiently
using jruby so the types of data we
worked with
was genes so we went into all the public
databases
and we took all the information we could
about genes most of them have downloads
available
some others we had to apply and get
permission to take the information
we took information about genomes we did
biomarkers which is anything any
relevant
bio biological
indicator within a patient so a
biomarker can be something like a
version of your gene it can be a type of
protein that's getting expressed very
highly
so that entire sentence is sometimes
called a biomarker
so it's it's it's kind of like a vague
term but we try to understand it better
we
we learned about drugs we learned about
treatments
again we went into patient data we went
beyond just dna data we
took rna sequencing data we had test
results available from clarity for
patients as well as treatments they had
already been taking
so the dna and rna data again we took
publicly available data as well as what
clarity patients had
and tcga was our main source which is
the cancer genome atlas
they're pretty amazing they're releasing
as many sequences as possible to help
both research as well as
some sort of treatment applications
build off some sort of training model
based off of this data
and then was the important data which is
treatment recommendations so
that connection between something in a
patient and a viable treatment option
so we really had to tap into the brains
of the scientists we were working with
to actually get this
into code so this was fairly challenging
um
but and honestly to parse this data it
was it was
us talking to them all the time and then
we put it into excel files and then
loaded in
um cool so then was
once you parsed it i had mentioned we
made use of internal dsls
and i'm going to talk a little more
using an example
so for example consider
the concept of a gene so you'd read in
genes from
ensembl it's the name of a database
so you read many many genes so we parse
all these different lines talking about
a gene and then normalize the ones that
are common into
the same entity so we basically parsed
it and normalized it in ruby
and we turned it into a data structure
so it'll
which was actually a closure dsl so we
outputted a line of closure code
essentially um
which said gene that can have id blah
name blah uh properties x y z
um and this could then uh when we
decided to load it into our graph
closure would run we'd expand that into
an executable it was a macro so it would
expand and it would load
that data into our neo4j database so we
would create a node named gene
that can have a relationship of location
to a chromosome
say seven et cetera et cetera
cool so um like i mentioned the choice
for our graph was neo4j
we knew this particular domain
especially it made total sense to look
at things in terms of a graph
so you could again have a gene that has
a dna version
an rna version a protein version a gene
that's present in a patient
a gene that can have a particular
mutation that can have a treatment
option
and at any given point you can induce
subsets of this graph
to get information that's relevant to
you
so um along the next important step
though
is actually we loaded up the database
but now you need it to get the viable
treatment option out what did we do
there
so um in order to create what we called
implications
we used the language we used disclosure
and basically what we did here is
link up everything in a meaningful
fashion and in order
the most important or sort of the magic
here was our ability
to take any any data point in a patient
and be able to convert it into a
patient biology marker that had a viable
treatment option
sorry that's a really long sentence so
say someone has a dna
mutation of x what we would do
is be able to translate that into what
the corresponding rna mutation is
and and guesses at what the different
protein
mutations could be we calculated some
scores related to that
and then we were able to connect that up
with what we already knew about
mutations and treatment options
and induce a subset that we could then
present to the oncologist with the
entire line of evidence
and they can then choose and see if that
makes sense
um so all of this magic or i like to
call it magic but this
um was done in closure and i would i
i really so when we first chose this
we did it because this particular
working with this data
it it really made sense to do it in a in
in functional style
because the data isn't what was
important but how we worked with it
was what was what was the crux of the
system
but the more we used it it was it was
the perfect choice
we couldn't have done it in anything
else i think and the thing that we
particularly used
is macros so we wrote a ton of macros
and it made our life so easy
and i worked on this for almost a year
and i think the production code was
about 300 lines
so it's pretty awesome um
so finally was actually our front end so
we had to display something
we really tried to do user-centric
design here so we had clarity and then
we had clarity's users
we try to engage with them throughout to
try to see exactly what kinds of
information mattered
into the oncologist as well as to the
patient and what was important in the
conversation
we started out doing like fancy things
like the physics engine
we went to town with d3 we did
processing we did
canvas svg and then threw everything
away because nobody liked it
what they wanted was a table and they
just wanted columns and clearly
bold letters explaining important points
that's all um so that was great we
learned a lot
and we got to play with some tools and
we also tried to entice them
and and you know be like we actually
even built like a javascript console
visualization
and we're like you can be a power user
and it was it was a fail
um so great again just
the end-to-end flow of our system is
this like i mentioned before
j ruby was very helpful in helping us
unify
combine a lot of data convert them into
closure dsls
we then expanded that and put it into
the neo4j graph
we deduced and built evidence all in
closure
and finally our front end the main
technologies was
composure coffeescript we used hamel and
sas
another just a shout out was from the
first week we started developing we also
focused a lot on being able to go to
production
because we realized no matter how little
or how much we find
the use is only if some if the if
clarity and then the patient can use it
and we coded our infrastructure code in
python
and we used amazon web services and
puppet to help provision things
and all that so a summary of what we did
get to achieve
so today clarity has scale treatment we
released production late last year
and actually all this effort to get
things working for clarity took us
about three months and we were very
happy with that
so they were treating about 10 patients
a month and i think they've grown
and so at that point they had done 300
in total and now they're close to almost
increasing that by scale
by a thousand more so we're glad we were
able to help
and we also were able to build an
evidence-based system so
not only did we just give treatment
options we provided that entire history
so clarity and the patient could have a
good conversation and it was more
contextualized
and then we also came up with a few
alternative alternate
i can't say that word alternate
therapies um
that even wasn't there in clarity's
initial sort of
uh guesses um so yeah that that was
pretty exciting and we hoped it was
useful
so the learnings um we had some big
issues
and this was a learning actually i
wasn't kidding about a lot of data
it was a lot a lot a lot and it was easy
to get lost
and the other part was a lot of it is
very poor quality
so different universities different
researchers everybody
has a different reason why they're
looking at this data and how they input
it
most of them are just open text fields
where you can write whatever you want
so people will define things completely
differently
and we we there was we had to really
sort of think about how we would
normalize this and actually
know that this x and that y actually
means the same thing
um that initially was very uh
disheartening or not disheartening but
it scared us
but we learned to live with it
people are also used to manual
intervention a lot so research
scientists
all the gold is in their minds and they
like to do things manually they like to
cross-check
so getting them to trust the automation
and
trust code was was quite difficult
as well as a lot of the the tools we had
to use in order to
download as well as get some of this rna
and other type of data
we had to use toolsets written again by
research institutions and academics
so they don't write code for production
they write code for a reason and then
they just do that and that's great
but it's very hard to reuse um it's hard
for them to maintain
and there's so much of recreating the
wheel so every again
big research institution does the same
thing they all do it differently
and that's weird um so
things we did to mitigate some of this
was again like i mentioned
we took it from everywhere so the common
practice is normally to pick your best
source
we just took it all and we were able to
do this again because we
were in when we started we built a
pipeline where
after that parsing and normalizing we
weren't dependent on the source anymore
everything was very generic
so that was the only place where we had
to tweak things when the source
changed instead of building an
end-to-end that was dependent on the
on the way the data was defined in that
particular source
another thing we started to build into
our system is feedback and learning
we did this actually by just putting in
code by hand right now so
when we learned some particular output
of the system
meant more than what we knew about it we
actually put it in
to our code as facts actually we just
said hey
know about this that went into our
closure realm but our goal was to
actually put it end to end so
when someone clicked in the front end we
would teach our system that hey know
this additional piece of information
so some other things i just wanted to
mention was that it's important
uh it was very important when working
with this to keep up with the domain
so it's ever changing ever growing it's
also very complex
so we had to learn a lot about genomics
a lot about what it meant
a lot about cancer we had to read papers
and it was very interesting but it was
important to constantly
remind even as developers you needed to
know the domain
and then working with the research
community like i pointed out again it is
it is very different than working in the
industry
but this collaboration we can see how
important it is
um so it is again something we learned
but it was definitely
something that's not easy in the
beginning but um
but you learn to work with them uh
finally legal implications as well
there's a huge huge huge huge legal
implications to working with patient
data
working with um in general you're
working with life and death
you need to be very very careful even
with the downloads and everything else
just a heads up we did a lot of research
into
licenses and in what domain did the data
exist and if
if we can use it and why and and we had
to actually apply
to a lot of uh to a lot of places to get
access to things and stuff like that
um as well as we encountered
weird um and maybe wrong data a part of
it is that this field is
this field is changing so fast that
things get out of date very quickly
so something that was valid finding six
months ago isn't anymore
so you have to keep up with the latest
publications and things like that
but it turns out publications have typos
so
things will be wrong even there we found
a few um and then had to go and confirm
with
with um clarity and be like what's going
on and it was actually wrong
this was again really scary it's out
there but
i think oncologists and and other uh the
people involved in actually working with
the patients are aware of this
and they have a way to mitigate it i
hope
um and also finally we touch the genome
realm
there's plenty of ohms that all work
together to make us who we are and to
affect the prognosis of this disease
so there's so much opportunity it's very
exciting it's very interesting
so i just wanted to point that out
um finally yeah i'd just like to
conclude so i hope
um i we were very excited that we got
something in production
and um it was useful and helpful but
there's still
a long long way to go we touched on
ovarian cancer we also only
touched on the genome relevance to
treatment options
there's so much to be done and i really
encourage everybody
as a developer to put on your thinking
hats and
get involved in this community and
hopefully
software can help make this make this
progress even
faster thank you
yes we did so we had about 300 from
clarity so we were able to confirm
did it match up with things that came up
for them
we did uh so yes we of course we did
which was good
um we learned a lot from that and that
sort of was the start of the facts and
and kind of understanding those things
uh but we also um
what was i gonna say sorry i'm blanking
out
um we also found that we were coming up
with more options
so yeah
um i don't know the exact number james
do you
like i know the number of nodes we have
over like a million nodes
um and and relationships and things like
that in terms of just the size i
i don't actually know
so we don't save that straight into the
database at all so we
enter yeah
so you talked a lot about the size of
the data on the geoscience
how big was the treatment option data
set how much how many
very very very much smaller so um
like do you want numbers or just like
order packages
the treatment options uh hundreds or
less or yeah
hundreds not not at all um
so yeah that's why i didn't stress too
much on it but that's the sad part like
that those connections
uh don't really exist in a format that
was easily consumable at least
by us at that point and then so when
you're matching so you do all this
analysis
when you're matching to that um i
imagine you're getting a bunch of
different sources
is there is there one that stood out is
very important like this is
the most important matching is
statistical data that we got from
studies or is it kind of expert systems
stuff if you've got
doctors what was the matching between
yeah that kind of led you to a specific
treatment
is that does that make sense no not not
i don't think i understand
right okay so the matching itself is
that
um normally when they say this treatment
option is possible it will be like
blah protein is expressed or something
like that um
and what happens say you have only dna
data available
there's a way to make that correlation
to see if that blob protein gets
expressed
um and however though the more levels
you traverse
the probability or the chances you're
not really sure
so what we actually tried to do so
clarity has their own specific test they
run
so what we can do is give them that
recommendation like run this test to see
if that is actually getting expressed
then you match it up and then that's a
viable treatment option
but they had very specific things that
were tried and tested so they knew
for sure that if this thing happened at
the dna level it really meant that at a
protein level
which meant that treatment was was was
valuable
so in terms of the most important data
though it is what's in the mind of a
uh a genomic oncologist if you will so
clarity
actually had a lot more useful
information than the oncologist
themselves because they look at it more
from standard of care and
just from the outward biology and at the
cellular level
people like uh who are working at
clarity had the most useful information
yep
yeah that you can absolutely do so one
source is the
cancer genome atlas data they have all
types of cancers
and various types of data so dna there's
even a more like lower versions of that
which is called like bam
files and things like that so they have
things at a very low level as well
as more um they have protein level data
and all of that all available for
download
um but i think they don't let it be used
for commercial purposes
um we'd have to read about that but so
that is some a place to start to
actually try and test different
sort of ideas um and things like that
uh in our project we i'm not
i don't think we used anything open
source we definitely used
some open source tools in order to
understand the data
as well as start extracting some so for
example
from ncbi which is national center of
bioinformatics
we wanted to download certain subsets of
genes
and they actually have developers uh who
write some code to help you
actually pass in some sort of query and
get only whatever you want back
so that was again i think he wrote his
in python and you actually had to get
the code
um use that in order to bring down that
data so that's sort of the extent
to which we used the open source tools
available but there's definitely plenty
and i also think um
there's some of them are very open to
developers going in and actually
suggesting like refactorings and
maintainability suggestions and i can
give you more examples like i don't know
off the top of my head but i've
definitely heard it being talked about
cool um i think we're two minutes over
time so
thank you very much
[Applause]